what's up
[Music]
somebody tell me why this was never in
any of meta's presentations how is me
putting a phone camera in the quest Pro
had said the most compelling demo of the
r I've seen in like the last five years
but I have
some hot takes on this whole metaverse
thing that I kept to myself for a little
while but I think it's finally time to
share them so buckle up let's get into
it so meta stock is down over 60 percent
this year Facebook's growth has
flatlined and their CEO Mark Zuckerberg
has doubled down on this commitment to
the whole metaverse thing which they've
continued to pour tons and tons of money
into it's like what is going on here but
let me let's just zoom out a second and
start with some definitions VR is
virtual reality which is you know
putting the headset on and being
completely immersed in a new virtual
world AR is augmented reality which is
overlaying virtual things on top of the
real world I'm gonna use those a lot in
this video those two things though are
both particularly hard to demo you kind
of have to try it and use it to actually
understand it and appreciate it so I
know there's a lot of curiosity about VR
especially lately and it can be kind of
hard to tell if it's like just another
Trend in Tech like 3D TVs whatever
happened to those or if it's actually
the future that we'll all be living in
like ready player one or maybe more like
Wally hard to tell either way there's
basically one visible Mega company
that's clearly pushing all their chips
in on this definitely being our future
and that's meta formerly known as
Facebook with their CEO Mark Zuckerberg
this guy this guy right here and he
explained to me many times that they
really believe in this metaverse thing
and he showed me all this Quest Pro
stuff right before it was announced on
stage so I got to form my opinions on it
before the slightly more cringe-worthy
presentation version we've all seen the
the metaverse might have a pretty
terrible reputation already but let's
try to take a step back look at it
objectively like a piece of tech shall
we
[Music]
so like I said VR is one of those things
you kind of have to try to understand
and appreciate but also the spectrum of
how much people care about the metaverse
is hilarious like all the way from not
caring at all and never having tried VR
in their life all the way to like
serious Believers like companies hiring
a chief metaverse officer and a
metaverse being in every headline and
just like a weird obsession with it so
it can be kind of hard to give a single
answer to this but I actually think it's
pretty simple the internet as we have it
right now is mostly controlled by two
things ads and devices so if you control
the ads then you're the one connecting
people to the things that they buy
that's basically what Google does like
Google's job is to know everything they
possibly can about people and then show
them ads for things not just on Google
search results but all over the Internet
with Google Adwords pretty much every
company in the world who does online
advertising pays Google to do it for
them so for as much as we talk about
like the pixel and Google Chrome and
Android on this channel Google is is at
its core and adds business and then if
you control the devices people use then
you very much have control over what
makes it to people's eyeballs Facebook
has wanted to make a popular device but
they don't make one trust me they've
tried but now in 2022 as popular as
Facebook is they have clearly saturated
the market they've peaked they've begun
their inevitable very slow Decline and
so they're they've made their bazillions
of dollars but now with things like the
iPhone adding that ask app not to track
button that took a multi-billion dollar
chunk out of Facebook's ads business
didn't really hurt Google as much
because people still go to google.com
and type in a box what they're looking
for Google still knows a lot about
people so bottom line bottom line is
Facebook is accepting that L you know
they they dominated the early parts of
the internet and that was great but now
the slow decline has begun and they're
moving on to the next big thing
and if you could look all around at all
the technologies that could maybe be the
next big thing that one thing that keeps
bubbling back up to the surface has been
VR and AR and so Facebook meta can
control as much of this VR future as
possible the software the hardware the
ads the things that make it to people's
eyeballs then they will regain the
control and the money that they're after
so cue them rebranding themselves to
meta and pouring billions and billions
of dollars into that exact Mission
okay so this might be kind of a hot take
but the meta Quest Pro this headset
is 1500 and I'll explain the thinking
behind that in a second but it is
actually pretty good it's a pretty good
technologically speaking a pretty good
headset it is much more comfortable than
a lot of others I've tried so they've
split the components now between the
displays and lenses in the front and
speakers and buttons through the middle
and then the battery at the back it is
it is lighter than it looks but I think
it's more about the balance and the
weight here you can see feels like the
balance point is right in the middle
there which is better but then you put
it on and you look like this here you go
boom and without the uh blockers on the
side there is a little bit of a gap and
you do have peripheral vision light
coming in from the sides and not the top
inside there is a custom Snapdragon xr2
plus processor 256 gigs of storage 12
gigs of RAM and then a Slimmer set of
displays and lenses and then the screens
inside are giving you 1920 by 1800 per
eye at up to 90 FPS and I can do this
decent full color pass-through with the
10 sensors and cameras scattered around
the outside it's not the best
pass-through I've ever seen but it does
work and it lets you feel like you're in
a normal environment plus there's these
new touch Pro controllers which have
cameras and sensors of their own and
they all charge on a single dock through
some pins which we'll be doing often
because sadly the headset does just have
like a one and a half hour battery life
when unplugged but then there's also a
suite of sensors on the inside facing
your eyes facing your face for face
tracking okay right now I'm looking at
an alien face
but a little bit more interesting than
that is the alien face is in real time
showing what the headset sees my face
doing and so every expression that I
make every little facial movement oh the
eye movements the
every it's it's kind of a lot of the
little things too like the little
muscles on your face that move when you
talk and you make little micro
Expressions so if I was in a virtual
world and trying to convey emotions to
another person
then they would see
everything
that's pretty cool VR and AR both worked
pretty well through this headset but at
the end of the day it still is a pretty
chunky
it's a pretty big headset it doesn't
fold down either so if you want to
travel with it you need like a bag or a
backpack this version might not be
tempting to you Zuckerberg keeps telling
me you know people buy a new two
thousand dollar machine as their desktop
computer all the time and this is maybe
a replacement for that someday but this
might not be tempting to you but
theoretically in a couple of years a new
version of it is much much smaller
closer to like a regular pair of glasses
and then even further down the road
another version is even smaller maybe
lightweight like Google Glass used to be
back in the day and then eventually it's
an incredible actually portable piece of
tech and so theoretically if you pour
enough money and talent into something
it can become amazing
which leads me to my next point
this is the real question here every
time I see a new VR headset pop up
whether it's this like pico Pro headset
or the metaquest pro or anything like
that the question is always like is this
VR thing really actually going to be the
future like it's cool with tech and it
works and everything but are we actually
going to be spending meaningful time in
VR at some point and the answer of
course depends on who you ask obviously
I feel like I've noticed the younger the
person is that you talk to the more
likely they are to want to give VR a
chance or to try it more often but if
you ask meta if you ask anyone in
leadership at meta the answer is yes
absolutely 100 this is the future that
we are all going to be living in using
VR all the time metaverse for sure now
of course they have to believe in that
because the whole company is a huge ship
barreling in that exact Direction but
also watching the presentation of
everything at the meta connect keynote
as miserable and awkward as as it was
the more you watch the more it kind of
crystallizes their whole plan for me
basically step one think of all the
things people normally do on the
internet step two make those things in
VR and then pour tons of money into them
and then that's kind of the whole plan
if you get the time and you actually get
to watch through that presentation
it happens over and over again where
basically they realize that people do
certain things in real life and then
they want to bring that thing into VR oh
you'd like to do this here's a VR
version Oh you do this other thing
here's a VR version over and over again
and ideally for them anyway convincing
people to use the VR version just will
become a matter of making the VR version
really really good hopefully better than
the real life version and that's where I
think my hot day comes in which is that
some of these VR applications are
actually scary good and starting to look
better than the non-vr version and for
meta if they can get enough of these
things to be real then they'll be making
this metaverse thing happen Gretchen
stop trying to make metaverse happen
it's not going to happen Okay so some
are easier than others right gaming yeah
we've got some good games already in VR
now we got to work on getting more like
a better variety of games better
Fidelity Etc more immersion and pouring
money into this ecosystem will entice
developers to rapidly improve games and
make better games which is awesome but
there's more to life than just games
what else do people do all day in 2022
Zoom calls okay perfect yes they've got
Zoom calls but better they've built an
entire virtual meeting room experience
where you can do video conferencing in
VR with other people so you know some of
your friends or co-workers don't have VR
headsets that's fine they'll show up as
a floating video feed in the metaverse
but now with a bunch of people in
meetings you can talk to the people
around you you can do breakout meeting
rooms instantly really good immersive
presentations
Etc now currently as you can tell these
are all using these avatars and these I
think are bad they're pretty cringy I I
mean you can customize them of course
with a bunch of different things
different hair and features and outfits
and piercings Etc which is kind of neat
sure but you still end up feeling like a
metaverse meeting is just a bunch of me
characters from Nintendo Wii but it's
very much a stop Gap because we also saw
that meta announced this live Avatar
demo that looked absolutely wild to me
you can essentially use your phone to
take a scan of yourself and then the
headset takes that and puts a
photorealistic version of you into the
virtual environment complete with that
face tracking and eye tracking and
everything that we talked about before
that is super Next Level so you can
imagine now instead of just a zoom call
with co-workers a really good meeting is
a bunch of people from all over the
world all in one room with all the
advantages of the eye contact and
relative audio positioning and being
able to like lean over to the person
next to you and say something really
quietly just to them all this is stuff
that you can't really do in a zoom call
and so just replace these weird Avatar
cars with the hyper realistic ones and
they might be onto something but that's
just meetings that's not even that much
time what else people do uh maybe they
just work remotely period sure okay then
they'll build this whole metaverse this
whole Virtual Office Building for people
to work in so if they work all over the
world in different countries they can
all collaborate in the same spaces but
even the first thing I showed in this
video which is just simply working on
your computer which is a thing that many
people do for many hours a day and the
quest pro has native Mac support that
let me project my Mac screen onto these
multiple huge virtual screens so you can
take a huge triple monitor setup
wherever you go basically you can just
take this headset with you and do way
more with fairly high resolution that
can again get better with time and more
money they've poured money into
Microsoft to bring Office 365 and Word
and Excel and everything into work rooms
natively they've poured money into
Accenture to give them like thousands
and thousands of VR headsets to get
those people to use the metaverse to
work virtually all the time basically
meta can and will dump a ton of money
into this because that's all they're
doing right now there's like a a common
Trope that like if you want to make a
bunch of money as a startup right now
just make a virtual reality Tech startup
in some way and you will eventually
level up enough to just get acquired by
meta it's no wonder Chief metaverse
officers became a thing that became a
way to like make it seem like you might
get acquired by meta but that brings us
to the last thing
there's only really there's only one
problem that I have with all of this
which is that
one company controlling the entire
Foundation of this second generation
internet if you want to call it that
this metaverse
is a terrible idea so this comes down to
meta wanting as much control over this
future as possible Facebook was built on
someone else's Foundation they want to
build the next foundation and then be
the ones responsible for everything that
grows up on top of it the the work rooms
the games the experiences everything so
that they're pretty visibly pouring as
much money into it now as possible to
get as far ahead as possible now plenty
of other companies are are developing
and making really cool VR stuff now
along those same lines don't get me
wrong there's the Pico headset I just
showed you there are stuff from Google
stuff from I think we all expect in the
next year so Apple to finally unveil
their VR headset which I think will make
meta a little bit nervous because Apple
will for sure make sure that's the best
one for iPhone users but meta has
already you know made so many
connections and and built so many
Technologies and bought up so many VR
companies and VR Studios that
it sucks but it's like if there's any
company that can be positioned to bring
this technology over the hump to make it
a thing then it's meta but the downside
of that one especially this company
having possibly that much control over
people and over the future of the
internet and possibly doing crazy things
like like using eye tracking to make
sure you see certain ads
is way too much for me to want to root
for it at all I've said it before but
when companies truly compete that is
actually when we win when there's
actually real incentive to get better
because competition makes them better
that's when we get better stuff
but man Mark's metaverse money
might make the meta thing much more
mainstream
or maybe not
thanks for watching
catch you guys later peace
[Music]